because you've also dominated the
offensive glass chances are you'll get
more than one opportunity
here comes Campbell the other way
stripped to the ball foul UCLA
I mean he's on the S in March Madness
that is a long shot he took it from Reno
and he cashed in
it's only fitting that he hit the shot
from the March Madness logo that was so
deep with plenty of time you can't blame
UCLA for going under on that window
because you're thinking he's going to
try to turn the corner he's a great
three-point shooter but from there
[Applause]
they're trying to make an interesting
missing some free throws well the thing
is if he misses it here actually it
keeps UCLA from being able to throw the
ball up the court on the pass the only
thing you can do if he misses now is try
to make one from 85 90 feet you're right
if he misses the clock starts when
somebody touches the ball if he makes it
the clock stays at 1.1 and that gives
UCLA a chance to take the ball out of
bounds all goalie in this situation we
make it and then you can't lose the game
on a wild shot oh I would try to make it
if I'm the coach I'm not having him try
to miss
UCLA is out of timeouts Gonzaga has won
1.4 the attack
that on strawberry
three-point game here come the Bruins
[Music]
and Campbell it would have counted at it
gone and Gonzaga survives they're going
to the elite eight in a thriller
[Applause]
wow
what a finish to that game we saw two
huge three-pointers down the stretch
strothers just trailing the play and you
figure here's a handoff and he's gonna
drive the ball but he pulls up literally
he's on that ass in March Madness this
is a long long shot
his third three 16 points the bench
loves it
Gonzaga now steadies itself for a game
against UConn
with a trip to the final four on the
line big hit Julian's trother a junior
from Las Vegas plated nearby Liberty
High School their all-time leading
scorer and comes up with a big time
three